what is going on
what is going on
michael is um sick and he wants one of
us to rescue i'm not sure i'm coming
michael oh i'm gonna save you
i don't know okay hold on michael i am
coming right there dwight michael why
don't you call your girlfriend i don't
have a girlfriend
but you said you went over this weekend
it was all made up just someone come
okay anyone anyone but dwight
what was that
oh
he hit the pole
it's broken right he can't oh my gosh oh
dwight
dwight
oh my gosh
is he okay
he's still driving
dwight
you forgot your bumper
hello
please don't send dwight does the skin
look red and swollen that's what she
said that's my joke damn it dwight
so yesterday dwight found half a joint
in the parking lot
which is unfortunate because as it turns
out dwight finding drugs is more
dangerous than most people using drugs
let's go over some of these symptoms of
marijuana use shall we
you tell me who this sounds like
slow moving
inattentive
dull
constantly snacking
shows a lack of motivation
hey
i like the people i work with generally
with four exceptions
but someone committed a crime and i did
not become a lackawanna county volunteer
sheriff's deputy to make friends
and by the way i haven't
hi linda
dwight schrute assistant regional
manager
you might remember testing my urine a
few years back when i was applying to be
a volunteer sheriff's deputy we test a
lot of urine
mine was green
oh right
how are you i'm all better
so i need you to do some work on the
saint andrews account i need your urine
i need some filing done what kind of
filing
cumberland mills
and how did you get my resume
oh no no i'm very flattered don't get me
wrong i'm just not sure that it's my
official resume or if it's something
that maybe a
satisfied customer posted online
what does it say under martial arts
training
oh
okay i'm gonna have to supplement that
could i have your fax number
would i ever leave this company
look i'm all about loyalty
in fact i feel like part of what i'm
getting paid for here is my loyalty
but if there were somewhere else that
valued that loyalty more highly
i'm going wherever they value loyalty
the most
hey how'd the run go oh pretty good i
finished that's great
why is that great
because he accomplished something what
was your mile time
about seven
i could beat that on a skateboard well
that has wheels yeah well my feet don't
and i could still crush that time really
dwight how fast are you let's just put
it this way
last weekend i outran a black pepper
snake
really
i am fast
to give you a reference point i'm
somewhere between a snake and a mongoose
and a panther
man what is taking toby so long oh i'll
just time him later and you'll compare
the times
yeah
are you ready now my questions are
really tight i can't
am i being mean to dwight
i don't know i did just make him run
around the building and i have no
intention of timing him
this isn't even a stopwatch it's a
digital thermometer
uh on or off
off okay
oh
what is on your face
is that a disguise
excuse me
paint
id badges are long overdue security in
this office park is a joke last year i
came to work with my spud gun in a
duffel bag
i sat at my desk all day with a rifle
that shoots potatoes at 60 pounds per
square inch
can you imagine if i was deranged
okay with all due respect to everyone
here i think the most worthy opponent of
you
is you that is correct
unless there happen to be measles
present so let's just say that dwight
has come at you with the throat punch
now how would you dwight defend against
it easy allow me to demonstrate
i am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes
block
grasp wrist as such and what if he comes
at you with the other hand because he
does have two
good points second throat punch
absorb the blow
groin punch
hip block elbow to the gut uh-oh up to
the nose no you're not ah oh
oh my god
he's making you look like such a fool he
really is
but not for long
ow god instep oh not again
you let go you let go oh you're right i
can't hold on
you two are so evenly matched i don't
know how one of you is gonna get the
upper hand the important thing to
remember jim we always have
what is called the element of surprise
ah
okay i will only need two things a roll
of duct tape and a knife
i'm on it okay 30 minutes or less please
come back
save the receipts
hey what let's see if any of these will
work hey hey dwight
dwight i keep various weaponry
strategically placed around the office
i saved jim's life with a can of pepper
spray i had velcro under my desk
people say oh it's dangerous to keep
weapons in the home or the workplace
well i say
it's better to be hurt by someone you
know accidentally
than by a stranger on purpose
[Music]
oh anyway
i'm going to be your new boss
is my greatest dream come true
welcome to the hotel hell check-in time
is now checkout time is never
does my room have cable no
and the sheets are made of fire
can i change rooms sorry we're all
booked up
hell convention in town
can i have a way to check out i'll have
to talk to the manager
you're not the manager even in your own
fantasy
i'm the owner
the co-owner with satan
okay
just so i understand that in your
wildest fantasy you are in hell
and you are co-running a bed and
breakfast with the devil
yeah but i haven't told you my salary
yet
go
80
000
a year once i'm officially regional
manager my first order of business will
be to demote jim halpert
so i will need a new number two
my ideal choice
jack bauer
but he is unavailable
fictional
and overqualified they will cost you
your life elaborate the worst thing you
can do for your immune system is to
coddle it they need to fight their own
battles if saber really cared about our
well-being they would set up hand
desanitizing stations a simple bowl at
every juncture filled with dirt vomit
fecal matter exposing yourself to germs
is the best way to make yourself
stronger so by that rationale if i had
to sneeze i should just sneeze on you
yes i would welcome it
you're welcome
the principle is sound to avoid illness
expose yourself to germs enabling your
immune system to develop antibodies
i don't know why everyone doesn't do
this
maybe they have something against living
forever
what is the most inspiring thing i ever
said to you
don't be an idiot changed my life
whenever i'm about to do something i
think would an idiot do that and if they
would i do not do that thing
care for a piece of chocolate chocolate
where did you acquire it that is a
delicacy in the amazon but it has not
yet been imported to the united states
who is the king of austria joseph ii who
is the king of prussia friedrich wilhelm
iii who is the king of england why the
tyrant king george of course
i don't care what jim says that is not
the real ben franklin i am 99 sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yes i have a wig for every single person
in the office
you never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone
i just want it to stop
you